merci de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes élu de la
Seine-Maritime à parenté au groupe les
républicains et rapporteur du projet de
loi de programmation de la justice dont
on va parler dans quelques instants il
arrive au Sénat cet après-midi mais
d'abord l'actualité vous l'avez vu c'est
cette nouvelle journée de mobilisation
la 14e contre la réforme des retraites
est-ce que les syndicats ont raison pour
suivre la mobilisation selon vous
écoutez je pense que il y a eu des
fortes mobilisations au début de l'année
au moment du vote du texte sur la
réforme des retraites c'est vrai que ça
a suscité on l'a vu de vivre et action
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut à la
fois tourner la page passer à autre
chose construire et d'être en permanence
dans l'opposition dans la rue dans
l'agitation ça ne fait pas avancer des
débats il faudra poursuivre ses débats
au sein du Parlement mais je pense que
aujourd'hui le temps est à l'application
et à la construction donc pour suivre
les débats mais pas sur ce texte je dis
il y aura l'examen de la proposition de
l'alliotte à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce que
pour une pivée qui dit qu'elle brandira
l'article 40 a raison de le faire oui
parce que je pense qu'il faut appliquer
la Constitution c'est quand même la
norme qui nous protège en l'occurrence
les dispositions du texte sont
contraires à la Constitution puisqu'il a
grave les dépenses donc il faut
appliquer le texte puis ensuite je pense
que en matière d'opportunité il y a pas
de raison de revenir sur un débat qui a
eu lieu déjà au mois de janvier quelques
mois plus tard je pense que c'est un pas
de sens même si les députés de
l'opposition disent qu'il y a pas eu de
vote à l'assemblée une pâte à
l'Assemblée mais ça c'est Impeca ne pas
faire d'obstruction et si opposé nous au
Sénat on a eu la discussion on est allé
jusqu'au bout du texte donc la
représentation parlementaire s'est
prononcée vous vous entendez les
oppositions notamment menées par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui dénonce un procès
en autoritarisme de la part du chef de
l'État vous comprenez cet argument
non pas vraiment parce que je pense que
à un moment donné il y a des débats un
moment donné il y a une représentation
parlementaire il y a l'expression elle
est permise partout mais ceux qui sont
aux commandes doivent trancher ces
principes de la responsabilité politique
une fois que vous avez été élu il y a un
moment donné il faut prendre des
décisions il faut écouter il faut
entendre il faut parfois trouver des
compromis mais il y a un moment il faut
trancher vous pensez pas que le fait de
ne pas voter je dis à l'Assemblée si ça
se passe comme ça ça peut relancer au
contraire l'incontestation c'est vrai
que le recours au 49-3 a mis un peu
d'huile sur le feu au moment de
l'adoption de la réforme des retraites
qui étaient déjà douloureuses là ça n'a
fait qu'amplifier on a vu la réaction
dans la rue
les Français sont assez sensibles et
sont très attentifs à ce qui se passe au
Parlement et à la nécessité d'avoir une
vraie représentation néanmoins là je
pense que ça arrive quand même moins de
six mois après un vote déjà existant on
va pas refaire des débats reprendre du
temps parlementaire on a plein de
réformes à passer à faire il faut garder
le temps parlementaire pour les réformes
utiles l'autre sujet d'actualité
malheureusement c'est une énième
agression d'élus en vous êtes
vice-présidente de la délégation
sénatoriale ou collectivité territoriale
vous êtes concerné municipal vous-même
un maire de nouveau agressé ce week-end
en Meurthe-et-Moselle à la manière il
s'est rendu en pleine nuit dans la salle
des fêtes de son village parce qu'il y
avait trop de bruit et il s'est fait
agresser il a été modesté comment vous
expliquer cette violence envers les élus
écoutez je l'explique mal c'est vrai
qu'on la voit monter en puissance même
dans
en Seine-Maritime hier je rencontrais
des mères je leur ai posé la question il
me dit oui oui on voit cette
agressivité souvent verbale beaucoup
plus rapide c'est vrai que le maire et
en prise directe avec ses citoyens et
aujourd'hui parfois ils ont pas de
filtre ils ont pas de limite et ils vont
jusqu'au bout parce qu'ils veulent avoir
droit et quand ils y arrivent pas les
utiliser cette force c'est déplorable
c'est vrai que c'est non on a entendu le
maire de Saint- matin on a entendu aussi
l'état et on voit bien aujourd'hui que
les mers se retrouvent aussi parfois
seules là du bruit dans une salle des
fêtes c'est aussi aux forces de l'ordre
d'aller réguler le maire IVA en espérant
faire de la médiation et que ça
s'appelle et on voit que ça dégénère
donc c'est aussi à sa Drôme du maire
seul dans sa mairie qui doit tout régler
au quotidien et qui est parfois quand
même peu accompagné par l'État est-ce
que ce sont des violences envers les
élus qui se multiplient ou est-ce que
c'est la parole des maires qui se
libèrent et c'est vrai qu'avant ils
avaient tendance à taire les violences
dont ils étaient victimes à ne pas aller
porter plainte et c'est moins le cas
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a un peu
des deux c'est-à-dire que effectivement
et c'est heureux les mères Arles les
mères portent plainte comme vous le
dites le maire médiatismes notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux les agressions dont
ils ne font pas parce que c'est
agressions elles sont inadmissibles
elles sont inadmissibles quand elles
concernent le maire elles sont aussi
inadmissibles quand elles concernent
l'entourage du maire parce qu'il arrive
aussi que la famille soit la partie et
ça c'est inadmissible mais il est
certain que aujourd'hui alors c'est
sûrement un phénomène de société mais
les réactions sont souvent plus hyper
direct elles sont épidermiques et ce qui
fait que bien ça dégénère plus
facilement David lister le président de
l'Association des maires de France sera
auditionné au Sénat cet après-midi
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de cette
audition est-ce qu'il faut des mesures
supplémentaires le gouvernement déjà
fait des annonces après la démission du
maire de Saint-Brévin est-ce qu'elles
sont suffisantes pour vous
écoutez oui il faut des mesures
supplémentaires le Sénat a fait des
propositions il y a une proposition de
loi qui est portée par le président de
la commission des lois François Noël
buffet qui vient aussi effectivement
renforcer l'accompagnement de l'État et
surtout aligner les peines encourues
pour les violences à l'égard des élus
sur celles à l'égard des forces de
police je pense que c'est une bonne
chose on va parler du texte dont vous
êtes là rapporteur c'est le projet de
loi de programmation de la justice il
arrive au Sénat cet après-midi il vise à
rendre justice plus rapide plus efficace
on va voir ce que contient précisément
le texte avec Alex Fossard
[Musique]
er les moyens du ministère de la Justice
effectivement Oriane ce projet de loi il
est inspiré d'une vaste consultation les
étages généraux de la justice qui ont
été lancés l'an dernier auprès des
professionnels du secteur également
auprès des citoyens et ce projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation et
bien il prévoit d'abord une hausse des
crédits du ministère de la Justice pour
qu'ils atteignent en 2027 11 milliards
d'euros écoutez le garde des sceaux Eric
Dupont-Moretti
sur les 5 prochaines années cumulées les
crédits du ministère de la Justice
augmenteront de près de
7,5 milliards d'euros à titre de
comparaison
ils augmentaient de 2 milliards
seulement sous le quinquennat du
président Sarkozy et de deux virgule un
milliards sous celui du président
Hollande alors à quoi va servir tout cet
argent et bien à créer 10 000 postes
supplémentaires dans l'institution
judiciaire 10000 postes dont 1500 postes
de magistrats et 1500 postes de
greffiers et pour le personnel de
l'institution judiciaire qui est déjà en
poste il y a aussi des revalorisations
qui sont prévues écoutez le garde des
sceaux
pas annoncer d'un côté le plus grand
plan d'embauche de l'histoire de la
justice et de l'autre ne rien faire pour
attirer nos compatriotes vers ces
missions qui sont des missions
passionnantes mais il faut le dire
également des missions très difficiles
et c'est pourquoi me semble-t-il l'État
doit leur manifester sa reconnaissance
c'est ce que prévoit cette loi de
programmation
qui entérine d'importantes
revalorisation et notamment une hausse
de 1000 euros mensuel pour les
magistrats qui sera effectifs dès
l'automne je vous rappelais qu'ils n'ont
pas été augmentés depuis
1980 16 alors ça c'est pour la hausse
des moyens Alex mais le texte contient
évidemment d'autres mesures pour la
justice prévoit une simplification du
code de procédure pénale qui est jugé
trop complexe par les professionnels du
secteur dans chaque juridiction sera
créé un pôle spécialisé dans les
violences intrafiamiales et puis à cette
loi va lancer l'expérimentation des
tribun aux des activités économiques
c'est-à-dire des super tribunaux de
commerce qui vont aussi gérer les
affaires liées à l'agriculture et aux
professions libérales Agnès canailler
est-ce que vous diriez comme le ministre
de la Justice que ce projet loi
d'orientation du ministère de la Justice
et historique
écoutez je ne sais pas si il est
historique c'est vrai qu'on peut
reconnaître l'augmentation des moyens
qui sont alloués à la justice nous
disons depuis plus années plusieurs
années au moment du vote du budget bon
là il y a un effort certain on aligne le
les augmentations sur l'ensemble des
ministères régaliens c'est une bonne
chose puis ça permet de renforcer la
justice qui était en France quand même
défaillante en moyenne depuis de
nombreuses années est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour remettre la justice à
niveau non c'est certain ce ne sont pas
que des problèmes de moyens c'est un
problème d'organisation du travail
d'ailleurs nous déplorons que ce qui
nous semblait est une innovation majeure
l'équipe autour du magistrat qu'elle
était proposée par les États généraux de
la justice ou un rapport de Dominique
Lottin l'autain soit dans le texte vu à
minima et resserrer autour simplement
des attachés de justice et des
assistants spécialisés sans prendre en
compte tout le rôle des greffes qui sont
centrales dans l'efficacité de donc il
faut revoir l'organisation du travail
des magistrats selon vous mais de quelle
manière alors déjà il faudrait évaluer
véritablement la charge de travail des
magistrats ça on le demande depuis des
années c'est un vrai serpent de mer
pourquoi
ça a l'air d'être compliqué technique
mais néanmoins politique mais voilà pas
politique et puis je pense que surtout
ça relèverait qu'il faut encore plus de
moyens que ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui
vu le retard de notre justice en France
donc c'est un serpent de mer on n'a pas
cette évaluation néanmoins
indépendamment de ça le sujet c'est
quand même à la fois de réorganiser le
travail autour du magistrat avec une
vraie équipe dans l'aide à la décision
pour permettre aux magistrat de se
recentrer sur son rôle de juge ça c'est
une première chose c'est aussi la
simplification des normes vous avez
parlé de la simplification du code de
procédure pénale je pense que c'est un
enjeu fort parce que aujourd'hui il y a
trop de normes qui ont été sédimentés et
qui viennent complexifier la vie des
magistrats
ce métier de magistrail il est pas assez
attractif aujourd'hui selon vous c'est à
dire qu'il y a plein de professionnels
dans le monde juridique qui ne vont pas
au final vers ce métier oui il est
peut-être actif c'est certain parce que
je vous dis les magistrats n'ont pas de
moyens ou peu de moyens ils sont quand
même bien juste d'être dotés
d'ordinateurs ils ont des environnements
qui sont complexes ils travaillent
énormément donc c'est vrai que toutes
ces conditions-là font que ce sont pas
ce sont pas des fonctions attractives
ensuite c'est compliqué il y a un
concours qui est d'un haut niveau pour
accéder à la fonction de magistrat ce
qui introduit le projet de loi c'est
aussi une ouverture dans le recrutement
puisque le garder sceaux veut augmenter
largement le nombre de magistrats plus
1500 ça veut dire qu'il va falloir aussi
booster les recrutements et ouvrir les
recrutements des magistrats pour ouvrir
la justice et c'est ce qui est dans le
texte de loi et que nous avons souhaité
renforcer par les amendements du Sénat
ce texte il est issu des états généraux
de la justice est-ce que pour vous il en
reflète vraiment les conclusions
pas complètement il va pas aussi loin
que ce que préconisait les états
généraux de la justice alors les états
généraux de la justice il faut rappeler
quand même que c'est la suite de la
fameuse tribune des 3000 magistrats qui
ont quand même tiré la sonnette d'alarme
on est au septième texte de réforme
concernant la justice depuis 2017 dont
le dernier enfin l'avant dernier
s'appelait confiance dans la justice et
on voit qu'aujourd'hui on a toujours pas
restauré cette confiance dans la justice
comment vous l'expliquer
parce que c'était des réformes
parcellaires qui venaient s'additionner
les unes sur les autres d'une part
d'autre part ces problèmes des moyens là
on va tenter d'y remédier et c'est le
problème aussi du manque de
simplification et du manque d'outils
notamment en matière numérique autant de
tribunal du Havre que je dis à du Havre
que j'ai visité il y a pas longtemps de
nouveau il me dit qu'ils avaient 80
applicatifs avec peu d'entre eux
connectés vous imaginez simplement
le travail que ça représente pour les
greffiers bref tout ça pour dire que il
y avait besoin d'avoir une vision à 360
degrés c'est ce que fait cette loi de
programmation et d'orientation sur la
base des États généraux néanmoins elle
ne va pas aussi loin qu'escompter d'une
part et d'autre part qu'est-ce qui
manque comme mesure qu'est-ce que vous
auriez aimé vous votre figurer dans ce
texte on aurait aimé effectivement avoir
une réforme plus complète par exemple du
statut de témoin assisté d'avoir une
vraie équipe autour magistrats dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure intégrant
les greffiers on aurait aimé aussi que
s'oppose est vraies questions sur la
réforme de la procédure pénale parce que
à l'article 2 on va habiliter le
gouvernement à réformer le code de
procédure pénale pour clarifier le
contenu refaire un plan du code de
procédure pénale sauf que ce qui est pas
ça qui est attendu ce qui est attendu
c'est une vraie simplification du code
de procédure pénale qui impose de se
poser des vraies questions de fond quid
du parquet qu'est-ce qu'on veut pour
l'instruction est-ce qu'on veut une
simplification des enquêtes etc etc et
là on est quand même parfois au milieu
du gué c'est vous dites que ce texte est
une réforme à 360 degrés ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous y voyez plus clair
sur la politique du gouvernement en
matière de d'institution judiciaire sur
l'avenir de cette institution judiciaire
oui parce que dans le texte il y a ce
qu'on appelle un rapport annexé et le
rapport annexé alors qu'à aucune valeur
législative mais c'est l'engagement du
gouvernement et c'est la feuille de
route sur les 5 ans à venir en matière
de justice pour le gouvernement donc
on voit effectivement
quels sont les objectifs à atteindre
maintenant on n'a pas toujours les
moyens parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
dispositions qui sont du domaine
réglementaire donc pour lesquels on n'a
pas une visibilité je pense par exemple
en matière civile sur le développement
de la conciliation et de la médiation
c'est promis mais pour le moment on en a
pas encore les contours c'est valable
aussi pour tout ce qui est application
des peines il n'y a pas grand chose
alors comme on nous pensons que
l'application des peines c'est un vrai
enjeu on a augmenté et on a fléché un
nombre d'emplois pour les conseillers en
probation et en insertion pénitentiaire
parce que c'est eux qui garantissent et
aujourd'hui ils sont trop peu nombreux
et on voit bien aujourd'hui ce sujet
majeur de l'exécution des peines donc
voilà sur la question de la lutte contre
les violences intrafamiliales ce texte
va créer des pôles spécialisés dans
chaque juridiction c'est la bonne
stratégie selon vous
oui c'est la bonne stratégie mais là
encore alors c'est des suites du rapport
qui ont été rendus par ma collègue
Dominique Verrien Émilie Chandler c'est
vrai que
aujourd'hui c'est un sujet majeur et
crucial il y a eu besoin d'une meilleure
coordination de l'ensemble des acteurs
puisque quand c'est un problème de
violence intrafamidale ça touche aussi
alors évidemment du droit pénal du droit
civil du droit familial bref il faut
mieux coordonner pour avoir une
meilleure prise en compte à la fois des
victimes évidemment des auteurs
sauf que ces dispositions elles sont
dans le rapport annexé donc c'est un
engagement ce n'est pas du tout
contraignant dans le texte aujourd'hui
le gouvernement s'engage à créer alors
certes ça relève de la l'organisation
interne espérons qu'on aille bien
jusqu'au bout de ce qui est promis les
Français ils se plaignent beaucoup d'une
justice qui est trop lente des délais
qui sont trop longs du 6 qui est parfois
peu efficace est-ce que ce texte dont
l'objectif est de rendre la justice plus
rapide et plus efficace il répond
vraiment à cet objectif est-ce que ça va
changer pour le quotidien des Français
nous l'espérons néanmoins ce que je
disais c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est
difficile d'en avoir la certitude et
pouvoir être sûr des effets qui seront
produits par ces réformes qui sont
souvent quand même très techniques parce
que si vous regardez le texte d'abord il
y a deux textes c'est un projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation il y a
un projet de loi organique sur la
réforme statutaire pour l'ouverture la
modernisation du corps des magistrats
etc c'est extrêmement technique c'est
difficile de voir les effets que ça va
réellement produire l'objectif est
effectivement de raccourcir les délais
je pense que nous raccourcirons les
délais que quand nous aurons en ce qui
concerne le pénal une vraie procédure
pénale simplifiée donc nous irons
jusqu'au bout du processus qui n'est pas
tout à fait prévu aujourd'hui dans le
texte du garde des sceaux quand nous
aurons de la médiation en matière civile
pour faire en sorte que on puisse aller
plus vite et qui est une meilleure
acceptation donc moins de voix de
recours mais là encore c'est la voie
réglementaire et on n'a pas le contenu
des textes l'ambition vous le disiez une
des ambitions des règles Dupont-Moretti
avec ce texte est de réduire par deux
les délais de procédure pour la justice
civile et pour la justice pénale ça vous
paraît réaliste ça me paraît surtout
très nécessaire il y a un vrai enjeu
aujourd'hui on peut pas se contenter
quand on a 18 mois pour obtenir un
jugement quand on n'arrive pas à avoir
accès à la justice c'est pas acceptable
aujourd'hui c'est pas acceptable parce
que ça fait naître une souffrance et pas
acceptable parce que
du coup quand le jugement arrive les
auteurs ne comprennent pas les sanctions
puisque il y a eu trop de délai entre la
le moment où les faits ont été commis et
le moment où ils sont sanctionnés donc
tout ça fait que cet objectif là il est
nécessaire maintenant je j'espère c'est
pour ça que nous voterons le texte qui
est présenté par le garde des sceaux que
l'ensemble de ces mesures permettront
d'atteindre cet objectif qui est crucial
donc globalement selon vous ce texte qui
est quand même ambitieux sur le plan
budgétaire va être adopté par le Sénat
oui je pense parce qu'il est
relativement consensuel nous avons
évidemment fait notre travail en
améliorant le contenu on aura encore des
débats qui j'espère iront plus loin
aujourd'hui et cette semaine en séance
mais comme il est issu des États
généraux qui ont été cette grande
consultation qui a permis de rassembler
toutes les personnes sensibilisées à ces
questions de la justice et prendre en
compte toutes les innovations même s'il
va pas plus loin et pas assez loin selon
nous c'est quand même déjà un texte qui
permet à 360 degrés de faire des
réformes sur la justice qui est plutôt
une bonne chose le fait qu'il arrive
d'abord au Sénat c'est un bon signal
pour vous oui mais aujourd'hui ça
devient presque la règle commence au
Sénat ou son félicite c'est vrai que ça
permet aussi d'avoir un travail de fond
si
c'est plus simple de faire passer les
textes au Sénat d'avoir un travail de
fond
de ce texte qui commence donc cet
après-midi on suivra bien sûr tout ça
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat à tout à
l'heure Alex on parlera de Marseille et
de l'opinion publique vis-à-vis de la
municipalité de Marseille ce sera à
suivre effectivement dans le club un
sondage il faut pour la tribune et
Public Sénat qu'on va découvrir dans
quelques instants merci Alex à tout à
l'heure on va parler d'Édouard Philippe
municipal du Havre vous le connaissez un
petit peu il a pris la parole sur les
questions d'immigration et dans Philippe
pierre un grand entretien dans l'Express
avec plusieurs propositions pour dit-il
lutter contre une immigration du fait
accompli c'est une expression que vous
auriez employé
écoutez je sais pas parce que ce sont
les mots d'Edouard Philippe néanmoins
l'idée est claire c'est effectivement
aujourd'hui on subit on subit cette
immigration
on subit l'arrivée massive d'étrangers
en situation irrégulière parce que dans
l'immigrations il faut aussi et bien
dire clairement les choses et distinguer
ceux qui viennent pour s'intégrer et qui
viennent de manière régulière et ceux
qui viennent de manière irrégulière et
c'est là où si tu le vrai problème je
pense qu'il doit Philippe dit les choses
il a raison de s'exprimer sur le sujet
il dit notamment qu'il veut s'attaquer à
trois non-dits parmi ces non-dits il y a
celui de l'islam devenu dit-il un sujet
central un sujet inquiétant un sujet
obsédant vous êtes d'accord oui écoutez
sur ce sujet là moi je d'abord un il
faut être très très humble et là aussi
dans l'Islam il y a plusieurs visions il
y a une vision qui peut être intégrée
dans notre vision occidentale et puis
une vision qui ne l'est pas du tout
celle qui est qui est proche de
l'obscurantisme néanmoins on voit
aujourd'hui que ça crée une vive
réaction je veux dire j'étais encore un
match de hand au Havre le week-end
dernier il y avait une des joueuses qui
était voilée et couverte moi je trouve
que c'est assez choquant
vous êtes conseillère municipal du Havre
et ici au Sénat où vous êtes apparentés
au groupe les républicains et alors
Édouard Philippe il dit qu'il comprend
l'objectif des républicains en matière
d'immigration qui veulent modifier la
Constitution pour faire primer le droit
national sur le droit européen mais il
dit quand même que cette proposition
n'est pas satisfaisante dans ces
modalités sur interpréter pour ce
qu'elle est une forme de frexit
juridique c'est aussi votre opinion
écoutez
mon opinion c'est qu'il faut aller plus
loin parce qu'aujourd'hui les réformes
en matière d'immigration on les a
empilés les unes après les autres sans
trouver véritablement de solutions alors
on va pas renverser la table entre
guillemets mais on voit bien qu'il faut
faire bouger un certain nombre de
contraintes qui pèsent sur la France et
notamment des contraires du juge
européen donc il faut trouver des moyens
d'assouplir l'application des règles
européennes et je pense que ça passe par
une renégociation une discussion forte
avec l'Europe et pour engager cette
discussion forte il faut avoir une
position forte au départ il faut être
clair dans ce que l'on veut demander et
je pense que l'intérêt de la proposition
des républicains c'est qu'elle pose
clairement le débat et elle pose
clairement des bords
je suis plutôt sur la ligne des
républicains au sens où elle pose le
débat maintenant je suis assez réaliste
comme les Édouard Philippe et je pense
que on pourra pas avoir une révision de
la Constitution globale et que il ne
faut surtout pas sortir de l'Europe
c'est au ciel qui nous protège donc il
faut être sur la bonne ligne de crête
comme dirait le maire du Havre il faut
trouver le juste équilibre et pour cela
et bien je pense qu'il faut unir toutes
les forces et c'est ça qui est
intéressant on l'entend de plus en plus
à Édouard Philippe sur de nombreux
sujets faire entendre sa voix il se
prépare pour 2027 écoutez je pense qu'il
y a pas l'ombre d'un doute là-dessus
pour le moment il gère sa ville du Havre
mais d'un autre côté il prend aussi des
positions parce que c'est un homme
d'État et qu'il est responsable et qui a
des sujets aujourd'hui
qui inquiète les Français et il faut
être en capacité de montrer qu'il y a
des personnes qui sont capables de
prendre des positions et puis de
conduire la France sur son chemin et sur
son avenir donc je pense que vous
souhaiteriez qu'il soit le candidat de
la majorité présidentielle et des
républicains moi je souhaite qu'il soit
le candidat d'une droite élargie bien
évidemment merci Anne escanaé merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité et
bravo hack qui monte en Ligue 1 on est
très fiers on les félicite merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin dans 20 minutes dans lequel des
territoires on parle de Marseille
comment les Marseillais voit-il leur
ville et leur mère à mi-mandat sont
d'agif-hop pour la tribune et public
c'est là que nous découvrirons dans 20
minutes mais d'abord on accueille notre
prochaine invité c'est Yannick Jadot qui
nous rejoint